plus la nuit avance plus Gary et Jim
sont sur leur garde
depuis mes débuts dans la police j'ai
perdu 8 amis des policiers que je
connaissais vraiment bien
je garde ça en tête quand j'interviens
je dois réagir plus vite je ne veux pas
être tué je veux rentrer retrouver ma
femme et mes enfants
[Musique]
me voilà à Johannesburg Jo bourre pour
les intimes
35 degrés à l'ombre
il est vrai que la ville est né d'une
fièvre la fièvre de l'or qui attiré ici
au XIXe siècle les Britanniques les
Australiens les Hollandais au
centre-ville les gratte-ciels souvenir
de la prospérité passée
autour des banlieues riches ou
misérables
héritage de l'apartheid
egoli la ville de l'or en zoulou ne
brille plus que par ses contrastes
accueillantes et dangereuse Johannesburg
capital économique d'Afrique du Sud
abrite 4 millions d'habitants qui
cohabitent autant qu'ils s'affrontent
noir contre blanc riche contre pauvres
homme contre femme jeune contre-vieux
ils font de Johannesburg une ville
insaisissables
braquage volamar mais meurtre enlèvement
Johannesburg est classé parmi les
mégalopoles les plus dangereuses au
monde ces crimes en disent long sur ces
fêlures
pour m'aider à pénétrer au cœur de la
ville des journalistes spécialistes du
crime qui depuis des années en arpente
chaque kilomètre carré
grâce à eux je vais embarquer à bord
d'une unité d'élite de la police pour
une course poursuite à plus de 200 km/h
je vais entrer dans une prison
habituellement interdite au journalistes
étrangers je vais suivre des gardes
privées sur une scène de crime ou un
cambriolage à mal tourné et sur les
lieux d'une fusillade
je vais apprendre à tirer comme tous les
riches Sud-Africains qui veulent se
protéger
je vais participer à un rodé au
clandestin avec des voyous
une jeune prostituée me racontera son
enfer quotidien
et je verrai la famille d'un adolescent
abattu par la police
et puis je finirai mon séjour dans un
parc naturel car en Afrique du Sud même
les animaux n'échappent pas la violence
bienvenue à Johannesburg avec en poche
un passeport pour le crime
[Musique]
j'ai rendez-vous ce matin avec un
confrère journaliste Graham c'est le
spécialiste du crime à Johannesburg
pour mes premiers pas dans la ville il a
réussi à organiser quelque chose de rare
je vais patrouille avec une flying
squadionit une unité d'élite de la
police sud-africaine
[Rires]
la voiture est puissante
gramme présente son ami Madeleine
joli sourire et gilet par balle c'est
une policière d'élite
sans les contacts privilégiés du
journalisme cette rencontre est
inimaginable en Afrique du Sud de la
police refuse systématiquement toutes
les demandes venant des télévisions
étrangères je vais prendre soin de lui
Graham ne vient pas avec nous je le
retrouverai plus tard
[Musique]
en écoutant le canal politique
et déjà un premier appel
combien de suspects il y a combien de
temps ils sont partis dans quelle
direction prends par là
vous cherchez quoi
ils ont cambriolé une maison et ils ont
utilisé le véhicule pour s'enfuir
aussitôt la chasse commence une chasse à
très grande vitesse et à contre-sens
je regarde ça regarde ça sur la file
vous avez peur de la vitesse
désolé vous avez atteint les 200 km
heure
pour ma première dans une voiture de la
police sud-africaine je ne suis pas déçu
il est où
la camionnette ce serait réfugiée dans
ce grand lotissement commence alors un
jeu du chat et de la souris avec pour
allier les habitants du coin hello maman
comment ça va est-ce que vous auriez vu
un combi un grand combi blanc
il est passé à l'instant
vous n'avez pas vu un combi blanc
non j'ai rien vu
la camionnette reste introuvable
mais la police n'a pas dit son dernier
mot un hélicoptère surgit en quelques
secondes depuis les heures la deuxième
équipe repère une camionnette suspecte
elle se serait dissimulée sous un auvent
les renforts arrivent s'agit-il de la
camionnette recherchée
pour le savoir
Madeleine sa technique elle touche le
moteur
le moteur est froid donc elle n'a pas
été utilisé
ici ça n'arrête pas on ne sait pas où
donner de la tête surtout des
cambriolages la journée la nuit
je pensais la partie perdue
nous recevons un appel une autre unité
vient de retrouver le véhicule blanc
alors c'est celui-là
c'est ce véhicule là qui a été volé et
ce sont des brouillés pour s'arrêter là
et les tips dans cette direction il y a
un chip là-bas
un des 10 pas été arrêté et trop ont
disparu
mais on les retrouvera jamais dans le
township
les banlieues pauvres noirs de
Johannesburg
la police a tout de même arrêté l'un des
voleurs présumés il attend dans le
fourgon
13 voitures de police et un hélicoptère
pour un simple cambriolage l'Afrique du
Sud a l'air de mettre le paquet pour
combattre le crime mais la vérité c'est
que ces unités d'élite sont rares et que
dans son immense majorité la police
manque cruellement de moyens
alors pour se sentir en sécurité à
Johannesburg les plus riches font appel
à des sociétés privées mais même avec de
l'argent
on n'échappe pas toujours au crime
vendredi soir dans cette banlieue de
Johannesburg les jeunes privilégiés
blancs et noirs se retrouvent pour
s'amuser
tiens la musique est américaine
ah le champagne français
mes adjointensburg la fête laisse vite
place à la violence dans les rues les
sirènes des patrouilles des agences de
sécurité privée se mêlent à la musique
ce soir je suis avec l'une de ces
sociétés
cela veut dire au risque
leur matériel n'a rien à envier à celui
de la police voiture rapide gilet par
balle et arme
très lourdes
je n'ai pas le droit de vous le montrer
à cause du règlement désolé parce qu'il
est chargé et armé mais c'est un glock
un semi automatique autrichien dont
raffole les amateurs d'armes et puis ce
fusil mitrailleur variante de la
kalachnikov difficile pour les policiers
sud-africains de rivaliser d'autant
qu'ils sont trois fois moins nombreux et
que la frontière entre police nationale
et police privée et mince très mince la
victime est venue
[Musique]
est un ancien des forces spéciales il a
servi dans l'armée sud-africaine et dans
l'armée israélienne il est là pour
protéger les clients de hihrisk mais des
rennes remplis aussi une mission de
service public comme un policier il
assure gratuitement la sécurité publique
s'il le veut et quand il le veut
d'ailleurs après quelques kilomètres il
repère des adolescents qui marchent au
bord de la route ils considère que des
jeunes noirs qui traînent la nuit dans
ce quartier résidentiel c'est suspects
alors il les interpellent harmo coin
qu'est-ce que vous faites là rien on se
promène
ce contrôle d'identité effectué par des
agents de sécurité privée sur la voie
publique est-il légal en principe seule
la police a le droit d'intervenir mais
manifestement tout le monde ferme les
yeux
finalement ces gamins sont en danger la
patrouille repart et aussitôt nouvelle
appel radio
donne-moi l'adresse exacte sur la 8e
Avenue cette fois ça paraît plus grave
en présence du couple les cambrioleurs
sont entrés dans la maison
les informations que j'ai c'est qu'on a
tiré sur les chiens
mais la police est sur les lieux c'est
tout ce que je sais pour le moment
des reines ne traîne pas en Afrique du
Sud un cambriolage peut vite tourner au
carnage
sur place les gyrophares éclairent la
rue
[Musique]
dans cette couverture les voisins
évacuent le cadavre du chien
l'un des propriétaires jérémy a lui
aussi était la cible des cambrioleurs il
est pas mort mais on lui a tiré dessus
il a une hémorragie interne un organe
vital peut être touché son état est très
inquiétant il est évacué par une
ambulance
la scène de crime a été gelée ce qui
veut dire qu'en principe elle est
interdite à quiconque n'est pas policier
mais deren semble s'en moquer et une
fois à l'intérieur avec ses hommes voilà
qu'il débute une enquête en parallèle
des forces de l'ordre
suspects description quelque chose non
les propriétés n'ont rien vu
les mecs portaient des masques et des
gants
masquer et gantés les cambrioleurs non
manifestement pas laissé d'indices un
voisin parle d'une voiture rouge
des reines lancent aussitôt un avis de
recherche à toutes les patrouilles de
haïrisk
as
rouge
de suspects tous les deux armés qui
portent masque et gants c'est tout ce
que je sais pour l'instant
la police sud-africaine repère la
présence de notre caméra les inspecteurs
nous demandent d'arrêter de filmer
ils veulent confisquer notre cassette
nous refusons mais il est temps de
s'éclipser
le lendemain matin retour sur les lieux
du drame le quartier a retrouvé son
calme sa mère et des amis sont venus
réconforterrés 44 ans le compagnon de la
victime il est épuisé
au téléphone avec l'hôpital il apprend
que Jérémy son compagnon doit être opéré
une deuxième fois il est hors de danger
mais son estomac a été touché et il faut
lui en retirer une partie
[Musique]
comme si j'étais passé dans une machine
à laver
j'ai pas fermé l'oeil de la nuit je
crois que je vais avoir besoin de
soutien
tu veux lui raconter ce qui s'est passé
dans l'autre pièce
[Musique]
nous étions en train de rire et mon
chien fidèle était allongé là entre nous
comme toujours
à la main
et quelque chose m'a fait me retourner
et là j'ai vu ces deux types près de la
commode
ici sur le chien et il a reculé
[Musique]
a lancé son verre sur lui il a juste
jeté son verre de vin et je lui ai crié
arrête
[Musique]
et après l'un d'eux pointé son arme et
me redonner de ne pas bouger
il allait sûrement tuer
là
avant que je réalise une autre balle
était tirée
[Musique]
je vous donnerai l'argent mais s'il vous
plaît ne tirez plus ne tirez plus ne lui
faites plus de mal
ils sont sortis
je me suis précipité à l'étage et j'ai
appelé la police
quand je suis redescendu en bas Jérémy
avait disparu
la tête sur le sol
vanouit ici
que voulait-il faire vraiment
vous voyez comme il a saignait
[Musique]
les voisins viennent à la rencontre de
Ré bouleversé et curieux ils veulent en
savoir plus sur ce qui s'est passé
comment sont-ils rentrés à l'intérieur
ils ont forcé le portail c'est pourquoi
la police relève les empreintes comme je
vous le dis nous avons surélevé le mur
que pouvons-nous faire de plus
les habitants du quartier sont
désemparés
c'est terrible
ils ont emménagé en septembre et ils ont
déjà surélevé le mur voyez comme ils
sont hauts
mais il y a tant de gens son travail ils
n'ont que le crime pour survivre
en Afrique du Sud un habitant sur deux
vies sous le seuil de pauvreté si
l'apartheid appartient au passé riche
des pauvres continuent de vivre dans des
mondes séparés
je comprends vite que dans ce pays la
sécurité tourne à l'obsession on me dit
que beaucoup d'habitants de Johannesburg
porte une arme
ok tu es prête ça m'intéresse
Mégane a 28 ans dans la vie et les
designers et depuis quelques temps elle
s'entraîne à tirer doucement sur la
gâchette
bonjour Christophe
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous entraîner
j'apprends à tirer avec un pistolet
oui
c'est la dernière chose c'est
l'aboutissement
à la fin de la journée il faut savoir
maîtriser l'armement et le désarmement
et sécuriser le pistolet c'est la partie
la plus importante
on s'habitue peu à peu mais plus vous
pratiquez mieux c'est
quand on voit dans les films je suis sûr
que je peux juste viser étirer mais à
vous voir ici
de savoir de quoi il est question
je voudrais essayer mais
cette main comme ça
et doucement doucement vous tirer
je charge l'arme pour vous
et quand vous êtes prêts
et quand vous êtes prêt doucement
doucement
détendu
ça y est c'est bien là
voilà c'est fini
ça va je ne mentir pas trop mal mais ici
le tir n'est pas un loisir c'est parfois
une question de vie ou de mort
je voudrais comprendre pourquoi vous
faites ça
vous pouvez être en danger à tout moment
une attaque ou un problème et vous ne
pouvez pas vous défendre sans arme
je ne veux pas être dans cette situation
et risquait d'être violée mais l'idée
est de s'en servir ou pas
l'idée c'est de ne jamais l'utiliser
sauf si vous êtes forcé à le faire on ne
sait jamais
vous voulez porter en permanence cette
arme oui je voudrais porter une arme
vous voulez porter une arme oui
j'aimerais porter une arme dans son
holster
nous pensons que c'est le rôle de la
police de nous défendre
mais c'est un grand pays avec une énorme
population et de nombreux crimes donc
vous ne pouvez pas vous attendre à ce
qu'il soit toujours derrière vous
donc vous devez vous équiper et vous
préparer à vous défendre seul si jamais
une attaque arrive
pour voir comment vous vous protéger
en Afrique du Sud le sentiment
d'insécurité est omniprésent je n'ai pas
vu de jogger courant seul ou simplement
de gens qui marchent dans la rue la nuit
tombée et pour se protéger les
Sud-Africains emploient très grands
moyens la maison de Mégane est une
forteresse
elle vit seule elle a déjà été attaquée
chez elle par des hommes armés depuis
elle ne plaisante pas avec la sécurité
[Musique]
alors ça c'est quelque chose de
classique il y a deux portails
vous avez le portail principal et ça
vous permet de stationner en sécurité
ici le temps d'ouvrir le deuxième
c'est pour protéger les voitures oui ça
les protège
et la clôture est électrifiée oui
toujours en marche toujours
vous avez des vidéos de surveillance non
je n'ai pas de caméra vidéo c'est la
prochaine étape non
pas de caméra mais une double grille et
une alarme
cette porte est verrouillée je peux
appuyer sur ce bouton le panic battle un
bouton d'alerte disposé dans plusieurs
endroits de la maison et notamment à
côté de son lit
si elle a pu dessus voilà ce qui se
passe
la sirène se déclenche et une société
privée de sécurité prévue
quelqu'un va arriver c'est ça
moins de 3 minutes plus tard un garde
privé là
merci pour votre venue
de rien nous sommes en train de filmer
et nous avions besoin de tester votre
efficacité
on est fier merci
je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous avez
besoin d'une arme dans une telle maison
vous êtes très très bien protégé il y a
le grillage il y a les portes il y a le
bouton d'alerte
ces mesures ne sont que des mesures
préventives nous essayons de dissuader
les criminels de rentrer dans la maison
mais certains rentrent quand même et si
vous êtes à l'intérieur face à face et
vous avez l'opportunité de tirer c'est
là le moment où vous avez besoin d'une
arme
et où serait l'arme
la plupart du temps devrait être sur
vous
mais si vous avez une fête avec beaucoup
d'enfants alors là vous n'avez pas envie
d'avoir l'arme sur vous alors vous la
rangez où
je le range dans le coffre
oui bien sûr
tout ça bien sûr a un coût Mégane me dit
que ça lui a coûté 15000 euros 60 fois
le SMIC sud-africain alors si les riches
ont les moyens de se protéger ça n'est
pas le cas de tout le monde et comme le
prouve ces images
les plus pauvres préfèrent parfois se
faire juste 10 semaines on appelle ça la
mobjustice ces hommes sont accusés de
viol
[Musique]
et celui-ci aurait volé sans procès il
est battu à mort
[Musique]
heureusement il y a Johannesburg des
gens plus pacifiques quelques heures
plus tard à la nuit tombée nous nous
retrouvons à Alexandra l'un des temps de
chips les plus pauvres du centre de
Johannesburg ici pas de patrouille
privée pas de grille électrifié ni de
double portail pour se défendre les
habitants du downship ne peuvent compter
que sur eux-mêmes il est 20h et voilà
des citoyens bénévoles qui ont
rendez-vous au commissariat
ce soir ils sont 56 jeune vieux homme
femme tous unis pour lutter contre la
criminalité en occupant la rue
de l'alcool dans la rue
nous recherchons les couteaux les
pistolets
ce soir il y a match de foot à Alexandra
la patrouille citoyenne est à cran
vendredi dernier un homme est mort
poignardé à la sortie du stade
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire que dans les tribunes ça
picole sec et à la moindre étincelle
tout peut dégénérer
je bois du whisky
[Musique]
en principe l'alcool est interdit dans
la rue alors à la sortie du stade les
patrouilleurs sont intransigeants il
n'hésite pas à fouiller les jeunes
supporters s'il le faut et carrément à
les arrêter
et pourquoi pour les interpellez
alcool sur la voie publique
on t'arrête parce que tu es une
bouteille dans la rue tu es arrêté
[Musique]
vous savez bien que la canette est pas à
moi
une canette de bière peut suffire à
terminer dans le fourgon de police ce
jeune homme passera la nuit en cellule
on arrête des gens
à la radio on prévient la police il
termine en cellule et son jugés
auxiliaire de police ils ont non
seulement des menottes mais surtout le
respect des habitants
comme vous savez il y a des types qui se
baladent avec des couteaux donc leur
présence est importante vous voyez il
fouille tout le monde leur rôle est
super super important
[Musique]
c'est volontaire font ce que la police
ne peut pas faire faute de moyens
séparés en douceur des hommes qui se
battent
non
non non non
un gamin traîne dans la rue il est plus
de 23h il le reconduise chez lui ses
parents sont tous les deux absents
attention à ta langue la prochaine fois
on t'arrête tu ne sors plus ce soir si
je te vois ce soir je vais t'en coller
une
on vous dit que depuis que les
patrouilleurs occupent la rue la
violence recule dans le temps de chip
d'Alexandra mais face au crime les plus
lourds ses parents sont désarmés car
Alexandra le crime et quotidien
le lendemain je reviens Alexandra
[Musique]
il est 14h
l'herbe et la bière tourne déjà
1 euro 50 c'est déjà cher pour un
Sud-Africain et le nombre de
consommateurs ne cesse de progresser de
quoi enrichir ces délinquants qui vivent
de petits trafics
celui-là est un criminel endurci c'est
cicatrice en atteste
en prison
je tuais je violet tout et n'importe
quoi
et je mets pas les gens comme toi je
l'ai tué si je tombais sur toi tu étais
foutu je te flinguais je te dépouillais
c'est ce que je faisais avant
[Musique]
il me surnommait slata
vous savez des surnoms de voyous il
trouve toujours des surnoms
je connais tous les voyous il y en a
plein trop
[Musique]
devant nous il dit s'être rangé
dans le quartier je retrouve à rillettes
l'une des patrouilleuses de la veille
cette mère de famille vit dans ce
quartier dangereux pourtant
elle semble s'y sentir à l'aise
je n'ai pas peur ici c'est chez moi
mais j'aurais peur d'aller à Soweto
parce que je suis pas de là-bas
ceux qui protègent ariette c'est qu'elle
connaît tout le monde
et me voilà chez elle
attention à la marche
toutes les maisons d'Alexandra ne sont
pas en dures comme celle-là est ce sont
ses parents commerçants qui l'ont
construite elle vit là depuis son
enfance
une belle maison avec tout le confort
moderne l'une des rares à avoir l'eau
courante
elle dort ici avec ses trois enfants
là c'est le coin que je prie mes
ancêtres
quatre fois par jour ariette prix pour
obtenir la protection de ses ancêtres
[Musique]
je vous demande de protéger mes enfants
et moi
[Musique]
que mon grand fils reste dans le droit
chemin que notre famille n'est pas de
problème
protégez-nous des balles
[Musique]
16 heures l'heure du thé son fils Tavaux
rentre de l'école
ta vaudois rentrer directement de
l'école ariette ne veut pas qu'il traîne
quoi
dans la rue et elle tue les passants
et du coup être arrêté par la police qui
pourrait penser qu'il trafic
ariette patrouille dans les rues
d'Alexandra pour protéger son fils et
cette mère de famille est plus efficace
que la police
je connais tous les criminels du
quartier
en uniforme mais ils ne peuvent pas me
fuir moi
est-ce que je sais où ils habitent
avec plein de maisons mais j'en connais
chaque porte j'ai juste à frapper et je
peux arrêter le criminel
Henriette a réussi à éviter que son fils
ne devienne délinquant bon élève grâce à
l'école Tavaux rêves d'un avenir
meilleur
je veux réussir dans la vie je ne veux
pas mal tourner
je veux toujours suivre le droit chemin
si tu vas à l'école tu peux t'acheter ce
que tu veux ta propre voiture ta maison
quand tu grandis tu réussis et tu
deviens responsable
[Musique]
responsabiliser les enfants c'est
l'obsession d'un homme il s'appelle Baba
c'est un ancien criminel il a fait 7 ans
de tôles et depuis qu'il a été libéré il
délivre la bonne parole dans les lycées
Baba intervient avant qu'il ne tourne
mal il veut redonner confiance à une
jeunesse sans espoir
vous faites ce que je dis mais pas ce
que je fais
ce que je dis mais pas ce que je fais
allez on y va sur le côté en bas en haut
devant
sur le côté
en avant
ne croient pas en eux ils vont mal
tourner donc ce message c'est qu'ils ont
une alternative à la criminalité
et ils peuvent vivre leur vie sans
commettre le
malin quand j'étais en prison j'avais
des rêves je voulais une maison je l'ai
eu je voulais un permis de conduire je
l'ai eu je voulais un bébé je l'ai eu
tout ce dont j'ai rêvé je l'ai réalisé
Babar redonne à ses enfants ce qu'il y a
de plus précieux le droit de croire en
ses rêves un vrai luxe dans un temps
Jeep
Baba c'est de quoi il parle à 12 ans
s'est révalués se sont brisés ici là où
son père chauffeur de taxi a été
assassiné
il a tout vu il a été poignardé par des
hommes qui voulaient lui voler sa
voiture
c'est la première fois que Babar revient
sur les lieux du crime
[Musique]
j'ai été témoin de toute la scène
les souvenirs me reviennent maintenant
que je suis là
je ne suis jamais revenu depuis le
meurtre de mon père c'est ma première
fois ici
je voulais aussi tuer leur famille
que j'avais volés
d'errance criminelles qui se sont
terminés en prison condamnés à 13 ans il
en a fait 7 7 ans pour faire la paix
avec son passé
et aujourd'hui avec moi il retourne en
prison
mais c'est pour raconter son histoire
aux détenus de renegging la même où il a
purgé sa peine ils veulent leur prouver
qu'ils peuvent s'en sortir c'est le
veulent
en principe les caméras sont interdites
mais grâce à Baba j'ai obtenu une
autorisation exceptionnelle
attention ils arrivent ouvre la porte
et me voilà dans une cour cerné par
quatre grandes cellules communes
[Musique]
64 54 54 à 54 dans la même chambre
comment est l'odeur l'odeur ça va on
lave trois fois par jour
vous passez toutes vos journées dedans
non la porte est ouverte on sort quand
on veut
à quoi ressemble une pièce dans laquelle
on s'entasse à plus de 50 toute l'année
je demande à voir une cellule
le confort
semble rudimentaire
ils ont la télé oui c'est une télé fixée
au mur
une télévision lilliputienne pour tout
le monde
[Musique]
les prisonniers s'entassent ici sur
trois hauteurs de lit perte de liberté
et perte d'intimité double peine
[Musique]
une seule salle de bain mieux
qu'ailleurs en Afrique certes mais pas
terrible
et un mince rideau pour s'isoler du
regard des autres
[Musique]
je me levais le premier vers 6h du matin
si je voulais prendre une douche parce
qu'après l'eau chaude il y en avait plus
ok
j'allais dans mon lit
bye bye de bonne humeur mais quand il me
montre là où il dormait
son regard se trouble
mauvais souvenirs
tu préférais celle du haut ou celle du
bas
tellement de choses me reviennent
maintenant
de la prison comment je vivais
je voulais vraiment devenir une
meilleure personne
devenir une meilleure personne c'est le
message que délivre Baba lors du cours
hebdomadaire qu'il donne ici
30 condamné sur le point d'être libéré
l'écoute attentivement pendant deux
heures
[Musique]
je veux votre attention faites le tous
tendez vos bras
certains vont sentir la douleur dans les
épaules
et parmi nous certains vont vouloir
baisser les bras quand ils vont sentir
la douleur
bras tendu Baba attend que le premier
crâne
c'est bon garde les bras baissés
[Musique]
épaulez-vous posez vos mains sur les
épaules de votre voisin
Baba demande à tout le monde de se
rassembler je me prête au jeu
et le surveillant mimi
je voudrais vous demander à tous
vous quand vous étiez seul
vous ressentez quoi
une division
[Musique]
la douleur vous avez senti la douleur
dans les épaules alors vous avez eu
envie d'abandonner
et là vous sentez quoi avec vos mains
posées sur l'épaule de quelqu'un tu te
reposes sur l'épaule de Christophe tu
ressens quoi je me sens mieux qu'avant
tu te sens mieux qu'avant as-tu
confiance en lui
oui tu peux
quand vous êtes seul c'est plus dur
mais quand vous avez des soutiens c'est
plus facile
allez maintenant tout le monde peut
s'applaudir
morale de l'histoire à leur sortie de
prison ils devront compter sur leur
entourage pour ne pas replonger
qu'est-ce qui a changé
quelque chose dans leur vie
pour le futur quelqu'un veut dire ça
vous allez faire quand vous allez sortir
je voudrais d'abord dire que ma mère est
si fière de cet homme Baba vraiment oui
elle dit toujours qu'elle veut le
rencontrer ce Baba elle dit il t'a
changé mon fils tu n'es plus pareil
avant tu crées des problèmes mais
maintenant tu es un ange quand
reviens-tu à la maison
quand vous sortirez oui je voudrais être
meilleur que Baba meilleur que Baba ça
va être dur
cet homme au passé violent a su briser
ses chaînes il est aujourd'hui un
exemple mais ces criminels le savent
leur premier handicap c'est leur milieu
et la justice n'est pas forcément la
même pour tout le monde
9 heures du matin j'ai rendez-vous avec
nos amours
cette journaliste du Daily Sun le
tableau ID le plus lu d'Afrique du Sud
couvre aujourd'hui une affaire de bavure
policière elle a reçu par email ces
images d'un jeune garçon de 16 ans tato
qui aurait été abattu sans raison par la
police on le voit allongé la chemise
ensemble mais la vidéo ne dit rien sur
les circonstances de sa mort
décide de se rendre à ses funérailles
régulièrement accusé de battre les
suspects ou même de les tuer c'est un
gros problème en Afrique du Sud
en arrivant aux obsèques à Soweto
surprise on chante et on danse autour du
cercueil tous sont vêtus de blanc la
couleur du deuil et de bleu symbole de
sérénité
[Musique]
et voilà la tente de tato qui évoque le
souvenir d'un bon garçon
j'aime rajouter quelques mots à propos
de mon neveu
était un garçon très obéissant
tatoo aimait les enfants
tato était un garçon très gentil et je
parle au nom de la famille
mais quand une voiture de police arrive
la colère prend le pas sur l'émotion
c'est perçu comme un geste de
provocation
[Applaudissements]
alors les policiers repartent
un voisin fait part de sa révolte à nos
amours la police a tiré sur ta taupe
sans raison
un policier a dit que c'était un
accident terrible
mais ma question c'est pourquoi pointer
un pistolet mitrailleur sur un garçon de
16 ans sans défense c'est ça ma question
nous sommes en colère à nous sommes en
colère contre la police les gens qui
sont chargés de nous protéger nous tue
alors qui nous protège
accident ou exécution sommaire que
s'est-il passé exactement il faudra que
je passe une tête au procès qui se
tiendra dans quelques jours
un peu plus tard dans l'après-midi je
reviens dans le quartier d'Alexandra où
une fusillade vient d'éclater sur place
je retrouve Narissa une journaliste de
la chaîne d'info en continu
des voyous en braquet un magasin puis
ont ouvert le feu sur la police
en commerçant en ville ordi portefeuille
téléphone bijoux et sont venus se
planquer dans Alex la police a eu l'info
ils sont venus les arrêter
la police leur a demandé de se rendre
ils ont refusé et ils ont ouvert le feu
et la police a répliqué
de son arrêtés et de son temps fuite
une fusillade en plein jour une balle
perdue aurait pu tuer un passant
ces jeunes du quartier ont tout vu ils
veulent bien raconter à condition qu'on
ne les filme pas ici on ne balance pas
tirer sur les flics et c'est là où les
flics ont tiré aussi
et qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
qu'est-ce que tu crois on a fui et je me
suis enfermé chez moi
ils ont tenté leur chance va saisir ta
chance et après tu reviens qui c'est tu
peux réussir ou pas comme
voler ces jeunes noires considèrent que
c'est un acte de bravo
on vole les blancs parce qu'on pense
qu'ils ont volé nos ancêtres
je ne sais pas si ils sont nombreux à
penser comme lui
narisa ils sont caméraman se dépêchent
le sujet doit être prêt pour le journal
de 19 heures il rentre à la rédaction
des news
[Musique]
cette chaîne privée créée en 2008 et la
plus regardée d'Afrique du Sud
salut les gars comment ça va
actuellement enregistrer mon commentaire
et te laisser t'occuper des images il
est 18h pas de temps à perdre pour
Narissa son sujet doit être terminé pour
le principal journal de la soirée qui
commence dans une heure
je la laisse travailler et Jodie un
autre journaliste de la chaîne
m'entraîne dans les coulisses et me
présente l'un des présentateurs vedettes
c'est une star
bonjour
cherche à comprendre que la place du
crime en fait dans votre programme c'est
une chaîne d'information continue
ça va dominer les gens ont besoin de
connaître la situation concernant les
crimes notre travail est d'informer les
gens sur toutes les sortes de crimes des
violences familiales à la corruption
gouvernementale
est-ce que dans votre propre vie vous
êtes touché vous par le crime
j'ai vécu en Afrique du Sud toute ma vie
je n'ai jamais connu une seule année
sans être affecté par le crime c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je
suis devenu journaliste c'est pour
pousser ceux qui nous gouvernent à
mettre tout en oeuvre pour lutter contre
le crime et avoir des résultats
est-ce que j'ai été victime de la
criminalité oui j'ai été victime d'un
adjacking victime d'un cambriolage j'ai
eu l'un des membres de ma famille tué à
cause de la violence
est-ce que j'ai été touché
personnellement oui mais je pense qu'il
serait difficile de trouver quelqu'un
qui n'est pas d'une façon ou d'une autre
était touchée par le crime
vous vous êtes levé
toujours je me suis levé à 4h du matin
alors c'est l'heure d'aller vous coucher
j'aimerais bien savoir quels sont les
limites que s'impose la télévision
sud-africaine quand elle court un crime
Jodie m'explique images à la pluie
quelles sont les règles finalement en
Afrique du Sud et ici dans cette chaîne
sur ce qu'on peut montrer comme comme
type d'image et ce qu'on peut pas
montrer
l'Afrique du Sud est à ce sujet très
conservatrice
dans ce cas précis vous pouvez montrer
le corps tant qu'il est recouvert
vous ne pouvez pas montrer le visage
dans aucun cas jamais
donc le plus que vous pouvez montrer
c'est quoi normalement peut-être le bras
et le pied dans ce cas mais vous ne
pouvez pas montrer le corps
c'est une position très conservatrice
effectivement en Afrique où en général
on montre tout et plus il y a de sang
mieux c'est quoi
c'est possible pour d'autres pays
africains mais en Afrique du Sud nous
sommes attachés à des règles strictes
probablement
voir en dessous du drap ne va pas rendre
le sujet plus fort
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal la fusillade
couverte par Narissa fait l'ouverture
la police a fait une descente à
Alexandra ils ont demandé qu'ils se
rendent ils ont refusé une fusillade a
eu lieu
me voilà au tribunal de Johannesburg
pour l'une des premières audiences
publiques ou comparer le policier qui a
abattu tato le gamin de 16 ans tué chez
lui à Soweto
toute la presse est là la mort de tatto
est une affaire nationale la chaîne
d'info news est là aussi bien sûr cette
fois c'est la journaliste banggawi qui
couvre le procès
est représentative de ce qui se passe en
Afrique du Sud et nous dit la façon dont
la police marche ou pas
nous avons eu de nombreuses plaintes des
temps chips qui mettent en cause la
police elle est accusée d'humilier les
gens et de ne pas venir suffisamment en
aide à la population pour les gens
d'étanchées le procès d'aujourd'hui est
vraiment très important ils veulent que
justice soit faite
[Musique]
sur décision du juge il est interdit de
filmer dans le tribunal nous voulons ces
quelques images tournées avec un
téléphone portable
l'enjeu de l'audience d'aujourd'hui et
de décider si le policier doit rester en
prison en attendant son procès
le voilà ici à droite
ça y est archi le décrit comme
suicidaire une commission leur est
assigné à des tâches de bureau avec
interdiction de porter une arme mais
alors que faisait-il ce jour-là chez
tato avec un pistolet mitrailleur le
rapport médical concernant le policier
n'a toujours pas été versé au dossier la
police traîne des pieds
la juge en conclu qu'il doit rester
derrière les barreaux alors accident ou
meurtre
[Musique]
j'ai bien envie de rencontrer la famille
de tato
au sud de Soweto
[Musique]
elle habite cette maison
bonjour
merci de nous recevoir on voudrait
raconter l'histoire de tatoo
pourquoi est-ce qu'il cherchait tattoo
que tato aurait une arme
ils ont cherché dans la maison
mais ils n'ont rien trouvé
j'étais ici et ils ont fouillé la maison
après l'autre policier a tiré tato par
la chemise ils l'ont allongé la par
terre
un policier a posé son pied sur son cou
mais moi j'étais là et je demandais à
tattoo mais tu as une arme et il m'a
répondu mes grands-mères non je n'ai pas
d'armes mais l'autre policier est arrivé
et il a tiré
combien de fois
une rafale
[Musique]
un voisin alerté par les tirs à tourner
ses images
quelques minutes seulement après la mort
de tato on le voit allongé sur le ventre
il a reçu 7 balles à bout portant
on ne voit pas les policiers sur ces
images on me dit qu'ils se sont vite
retirés près des voitures
la famille elle est réfugiée dans la
maison
sous le choc
ils nous ont insulté ils ont menacé de
nous gifler en disant qu'il cherchait
tato
ils sont entrés dans sa chambre ils lui
ont demandé de s'allonger par terre
ils n'ont pas trouvé ce qu'il cherchait
alors qu'il était à terre ils l'ont
donné des coups de pieds ils avaient des
grosses bottes et à la fin ils l'ont
tiré dessus
témoignage accablant pour la police
d'après ce que vous avez vu est-ce
qu'ils ont voulu le tuer pour éviter
intentionnel parce qu'il est venu il a
pointé son arme sur la tête de tato et
après il a tiré qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de la justice sud-africaine
je veux que justice soit faite
je veux que la justice soit faite parce
que même si tato avait une arme il
devait l'arrêter et le juger à l'abattre
comme ça devant nous sa famille
[Musique]
le policier a-t-il tiré volontairement à
ce jour aucune date de procès n'a été
fixée et le meurtre de tattoo n'est pas
un cas isolé en Afrique du Sud à Durban
à 500 km de Johannesburg une unité de la
police a décidé de faire justice
elle-même pendant plusieurs années
j'apprends que ces 24 policiers auraient
abattu 51 délinquants présumé ils seront
bientôt jugés et chose incroyables comme
en atteste cette page facebook
déçue d'Africains les soutiennent
si les policiers se comportent parfois
en voyous les voyous peuvent souvent
agir en toute impunité je vais m'en
rendre compte ce soir en participant à
un événement aussi mystérieux qu'il
légale réservé à quelques traits
cette nuit les voyous de tous les
tonship avoisinants vont s'affronter en
voiture au cours d'un rodéo clandestin
il est 23h à Soweto embouteillage devant
les grilles il va falloir être patient
et surtout montrer pas de planches
[Musique]
ici on parie l'argent passe demain en
main les voitures que je soupçonne
d'être toutes volées coûte une petite
fortune
ici les voyous sont bling bling
[Musique]
techno pierre et chicha la température
monte en attendant que commence la
compétition
c'est un goût de fruits
c'est trop cool
[Musique]
et c'est parti
la première voiture s'engage
[Musique]
grosse cylindrée préparé pour l'occasion
les spectateurs sont ravis
c’était de 20 mètres de diamètre et des
figures libres pour démontrer ses
qualités de pilote
chacun à son style
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici une interprétation toute personnelle
de la nage synchronisée
[Musique]
on tourne on tourne
parfois jusqu'à l'éclatement des pneus
[Musique]
alors bonjour je suis Christophe je
viens de France j'adore
[Musique]
les gens pensent que si vous faites du
rodéo vous êtes forcément un criminel
que vous voulez forcément des voitures
mais ceux qui font du rodéo ne sont pas
tous des voyous ils ne veulent pas tous
des voitures moi et d'autres on va à
l'école le rodéo c'est juste un sport
vous connaissez tout le monde oui la
plupart d'entre eux vous êtes ici de ce
où oui je suis de Soweto
tu veux monter
je peux monter on peut aller dedans
[Musique]
il est le meilleur c'est le meilleur
[Rires]
je laisse ces fous du volant brûler les
pneus jusqu'au bout de la nuit
moi j'ai rendez-vous avec gram le
journaliste qui m'avait accueilli au
début de mon séjour
il passe la nuit avec une autre unité
d'élite de la police sud-africaine et
m'a proposé de l'accompagner
Graham connaît bien Gary et Jim deux
équipiers de longue date
tu es fatigué non je vais rester jusqu'à
4 5 heures
la nuit est calme en ville
gramme les connaît depuis 10 ans il
patrouille régulièrement avec eux pour
écrire ses articles
première étape de la soirée le
commissariat une voiture volée vient
d'être retrouvée
la police est alors
[Musique]
j'essaye de trouver des empreintes pour
identifier un suspect dans nos fichiers
[Musique]
moins classique la voiture est
totalement désossée
[Musique]
les types qui ont volé cette voiture
cherchaient un tracker
dans la voiture et quand elle est volée
il envoie la police sa position
ils ont cherché dans le tableau de bord
comme souvent le tracker a fonctionné et
les voleurs ont dû abandonner la voiture
à l'arrivée de la police
du coup les criminels ont inventé une
méthode radicale
[Musique]
ils lui mettent un pistolet sur la tempe
et il le force à révéler ou est caché le
mouchard
ce qui devait être un simple vol de
voiture se transforme en crime sanglant
et violent
une fois n'est pas coutume ce soir la
police annonce une bonne nouvelle au
propriétaire
est sur le parking du commissariat la
mienne vous êtes sûr
il y a toutes vos affaires dedans
tenez je vais vous les rendre
toute ma vie était dans cette voiture
si cette histoire se termine bien ça
n'est pas toujours le cas plus la nuit
avance plus Gary et Jim sont sur leur
garde
depuis mes débuts dans la police j'ai
perdu 8 amis des policiers que je
connaissais vraiment bien
je garde ça en tête quand j'interviens
je dois réagir plus vite je ne veux pas
être tué je veux rentrer retrouver ma
femme et mes enfants
Gary déclenche la sirène une moto roule
tout phare est un sur l'autoroute
[Musique]
un policier ne sort jamais de sa voiture
sans arme même si la situation ne semble
pas dangereuse
Gary control si la moto n'est pas volée
il n'a pas son permis de conduire avec
lui il ne devrait pas être sur la route
Gary lui fait la leçon
à cet instant regardez bien derrière
cette voiture vient de passer à plus de
200 km heure
allez ok on y va
[Musique]
décide de la prendre en chasse
sirène hurlante et poursuit à très
grande vitesse
[Musique]
et on peut supposer qu'ils sont
lourdement armés
[Musique]
la voiture continue sa course elle ne
s'arrête pas malgré la sirène
il appelle des renforts
la direction Johannesburg d'élite fuite
en étant en train de poursuivre une
voiture avec deux suspects à l'intérieur
après de multiples appels de phares la
voiture se range sur le bas-côté
si le conducteur sera rapidement le
passager reste dans la voiture
pour les policiers c'est le moment le
plus dangereux cet homme peut être armé
le passager sort
fouille minutieuse à la recherche d'une
arme
ne me cherche pas repose tes mains
[ __ ] non de dieu c'est pas moi qui
roulait à 200 km à l'heure à l'instant
alors
je suis terriblement désolé ma mère a
une crise cardiaque elle est à l'hôpital
mais j'en ai rien à faire de savoir que
tu allais à l'hôpital
l'ambiance est tendue l'homme tente de
se justifier ouvre le coffre
l'homme dit que sa mère est malade
s'agit-il d'une excuse
Gary vérifie en cherchant de la drogue
et des armes il va pas être déçu sous le
siège du conducteur un pistolet l'homme
est-il un criminel
mets tes mains sur le toit je vais pas
te le répéter
je vais te dire un truc si tu me bruns
avec ton jouet je t'explose la cervelle
un jouet mais ils sont identiques
impossible de distinguer le faux
pistolet du vrai à gauche mais même un
faux pistolet peut servir lors d'un
braquage
vous pensez que ce sont des braqueurs
possible
tu m'as dit que c'est le pistolet ton
fils c'est un pistolet à bille le jeu
il repose tes mains je sais voir à qui
appartient c'est à mon fils à ton fils
alors pourquoi il est sous le siège
et là je n'en reviens pas le conducteur
se met à supplier le policier à genoux
accepter mes humbles excuses je suis
désolé plus surprenant encore alors que
la police sud-africaine à la réputation
d'être très dur Gary va se montrer très
clément et laisser partir le chauffard
le pistolet appartiendrait à son fils
c'est plausible
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle ne voit pas
la différence
mais la voiture elle est en règle
d'accord
c'est une voiture de fonction tu te
tends en règle donc
[Applaudissements]
on continue la ronde ici le quotidien
c'est aussi la prostitution Gary
s'arrête il connaît bien la plupart des
filles ça va comme d'hab les clients se
font rares ce soir et toi
elle a 30 ans maintenant elle dit
qu'elle a commencé à l'âge de 16 ans
elle était très belle cette fille elle a
plongé dans la drogue avec des Nigériens
et maintenant vous voyez à quoi elle
ressemble elle dit qu'elle veut arrêter
mais 99% d'entre elles ne sont pas
elle est en train de sombrer peut-être
même qu'elle ne sera plus là l'année
prochaine
en Afrique du Sud les prostituées sont
souvent de jeunes mineurs que des
proxénètes drogues pour mieux les
enrôler
un quartier chaud de Johannesburg même
si la prostitution est interdite on
trouve des femmes à chaque coin de rue
là un hôtel de passe tenu par des
Nigériens
les mineurs se trouvent dans les ruelles
les moins éclairées
une fois notre patrouille terminée loin
des regards loin de la police nous
rencontrons une jeune prostituée qui
accepte de témoigner elle n'a que 15 ans
bienvenue chez le One même si tu n'en
veux pas il te battent pour que tu
prennes du crack parce qu'une fois que
tu y as goûté tu veux ta dose
ça y est tu ne choisis pas de te
prostituer
c'est pas une vie que tu veux mais tu ne
peux pas t'en sortir c'est vraiment dur
il n'y a personne pour te sortir de là
pour moi il y a vraiment personne
ça c'est avec un tesson de bouteille je
suis tombé sur les genoux parce qu'il
voulait me brûler avec de l'essence il
avait une main sur moi et comme je me
suis protégé il m'a mordu
même si on va voir les flics pour dire
qu'on t'a battu et porter plainte il
s'en trouve toujours un pour avertir le
Mac il te menace de te supprimer et tu
es terrorisé
parce que ce ne sont pas que des paroles
en l'air
tu sais que c'est arrivé avant des
filles ont simplement disparu du jour au
lendemain comme ça
[Musique]
c'est pas une vie c'est l'enfer
là
[Musique]
livré au proxénète
elle ne peut pas compter sur la police
en Afrique du Sud la violence envers les
femmes peut prendre des formes
différentes certaines finissent sur le
trottoir d'autres sont violets c'est le
cas de Joe vôtre 36 ans violet quand
elle en avait 19
je veux m'a donné rendez-vous dans une
école elle donne des cours Matt elle dit
d'une curieuse façon
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous nous expliquer ce que vous faites
là
le but c'est qu'à la fin de la journée
je veux qu'ils apprivoisent les maths
les sciences et la comptabilité
il voit ses matières comme des monstres
des grands monstres que se passe-t-il si
à la fin de la journée par la danse et
les chants il voyait ses matières de
manière différente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le chant pour apprivoiser les monstres
et ça marche pour les enfants jovo est
un prof comme on en rêve une énergie une
joie de vivre qui les enchante
cette joie de vivre cage pourtant un
profond traumatisme
ah fresh pet sauf j'ai des flashbacks de
ceux qui m'est arrivé à l'époque
je ne dors pas la nuit encore
aujourd'hui ma famille vous le dira
je crie tous les soirs
tous les soirs encore aujourd'hui vous
ne dormez pas je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas qu'est-ce qu'il est arrivé
ils m'ont violé dans l'église
je suis restée nue à côté de l'hôtel ils
m'ont laissé marcher dans l'église
complètement nue
ok voilà ce qui est arrivé
j'ai demandé où en était la faire et on
m'a dit qu'elle était close
j'ai reçu des appels qui me disaient
attention tu sais à qui tu as à faire tu
ne dois pas parler
où j'habitais et même pendant le procès
le juge me criait dessus parce que je
devais m'asseoir à côté des types qui
m'ont violé sur le même rang
violet à deux
je le redis je ne peux pas mais le juge
ne comprenait pas
jusqu'à quel point votre histoire
est-elle emblématique
ça concerne beaucoup de vos amis
il y a beaucoup de femmes beaucoup de
femmes
68 000 femmes portent plainte pour viol
chaque année
mais on estime le nombre réel de viol à
500 000 autrement dit un par minute
l'Afrique du soutien là un triste record
mondial dans cette société violente les
femmes sont en première ligne
mais les plus vulnérables d'entre elles
les plus visées sont les lesbiennes
tous les assume elle aime les femmes
mais dans ce pays qui a ouvert le
mariage et l'adoption aux homosexuels
être lesbienne peut être dangereux
le principal risque le viol correctif
une manière pour les hommes de les punir
de vouloir les remettre sur le droit
chemin c'est ce qui est arrivé à tout
lui il y a 10 ans elle était adolescente
c'était ici un dimanche matin
et non pas un mec et souhaitent
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de maison
autour à l'époque
j'étais seule avec lui
il était armé d'un pistolet
il prenait son pied
je souffrais
je pleurais tout ça
j'étais juste heureuse parce qu'il ne
m'a pas tué
reconstruite elle habite à Soweto dans
cette maison avec toute sa famille et sa
fille
[Musique]
est une ancienne joueuse de foot
professionnel mais dans ce pays machiste
le foot c'est un sport de garçon
et pour sa famille jouer à un sport de
garçon
c'était risqué d'en devenir
[Musique]
il pense qu'elle va me ressembler agir
comme moi
elle va peut-être devenir lesbienne je
sais pas
les préjugés ont la vie dure dans ce
pays
tous les retrouve ce soir manie sa
petite amie elles sont ensemble depuis
un an et se retrouvent plusieurs soirs
par semaine
[Musique]
acheter des bières simple gestes de la
vie quotidienne mais pour elle c'est
prendre des risques
[Musique]
dans le township les hommes regardent
d'un mauvais œil de femmes ensembles
[Musique]
marcher ensemble la nuit n'est pas sûr
du tout
la probabilité est très importante
d'être violée ou d'être agressé par des
mecs
à la fin de la journée la vie continue
c'est pas parce que nous sommes
lesbiennes et que nos vies sont en
danger que nous devons arrêter de vivre
ici assumer
est un sacré courage
ce dimanche tout lit et sa compagne me
donne rendez-vous à Soweto pour ce qu'on
appelle un braille le barbecue
traditionnel sud-africain
du bœuf ou du mouton
oui ça c'est du mouton
allez c'est parti
oh la recette est simple saucisse viande
grillée et de la bière
[Musique]
garçon ou fille à deux ou à 3 ce pays si
longtemps pointé du doigt pour son
intolérance est en train de gagner le
droit à l'indifférence
avec les hommes avez-vous été je sais
pas attaqué par des hommes oui et moi
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi cette
société si violente est-ce que vous avez
une réponse à ça pourquoi l'Afrique du
Sud était tellement violente je crois
que la violence vient de nos parents
vous savez nos parents ont été abusés
d'une certaine façon et quand il grandit
ils veulent changer être bon mais ils
n'ont pas d'autre choix que de décharger
cette violence de faire le mal à leur
tour
génération même s'ils veulent faire le
bien il y a cette colère qui remonte qui
remonte de nulle part et qui les met en
rage comme à l'époque de l'apartheid
par exemple avant quand j'étais avec des
types je me battais en permanence avec
eux je les provoqué pour qu'il me frappe
je ne sais pas c'est une violence que
j'ai à l'intérieur
la violence ronge les jeunes
sud-africains une violence héritée d'un
passé qui ne passe pas des années de
lutte meurtrière de discrimination
comment briser le cycle de la violence
comment faire la paix avec soi et son
passé
[Musique]
mon séjour est bientôt fini
pour les touristes l'Afrique du Sud
c'est avant tout ça des réserves
naturelles dans lesquelles vivent des
animaux sauvages
qui vivent là dans ce parc de 1200
hectares à 50 km de Johannesburg
ils vivent libre mais soit de protection
car eux aussi sont victimes de violence
et en particulier les rhinocéros en
danger de mort sur ces images on
découvre l'un d'eux dans les braconniers
viennent d'arracher la corne les
Asiatiques lui accorderaient des vertus
aphrodisiaques du coup son prix grimpe
en flèche de Rhino est aujourd'hui plus
cher que l'or à 49.000 euros le kilo une
corne adulte se vend 400000 euros un
rhinocéros c'est une fortune sur quatre
pattes
cette espèce en voie d'extinction ne
survivra pas au rythme de ce trafic les
arrestations se multiplient les
tribunaux condamnent lourdement les
braconniers jusqu'à 25 ans de prison
mais rien n'y fait
alors les parcs cherchent la parade
comme ici je rencontre Stéphane et
demeure française sud-africain en charge
depuis 10 ans des rhinocéros
nous voilà donc parti pour 4 heures de
piste en jeep on ne donne pas
rendez-vous à un rhinocéros il faut le
trouver
vivre dans ce cadre là tu vas faire
rêver des gens tu dois faire rêver des
gens
nous parcourons les derniers mètres à
pied
nous sommes tout près il faut être
prudent
attention c'est à court ne courait pas
d'accord ils vont toujours donner
un signe pour vous montrer que ok
d'accord
les oreilles la façon qui bouge ça y est
donc là on peut voir la femelle jusqu'à
la fin avec sa queue
Rhino blanc ou un rhino noir la couleur
et identique c'est gris en couleur
d'accord pourquoi on les appelle quand
même Rhino blanc Rhino noir un rhino
blanc le jaune sera toujours devant moi
d'accord comme une femme qui vient
d'Europe ou d'Amérique il garde le bébé
devant en Afrique
les Noirs bébé dans leur dos et le Rhino
noir mais le bébé derrière
combien il y a de rhinocéros ici
on a pas le droit de vous
le dire
à cause des braconniers
secrets jalousement gardé la guerre
contre les braconniers passe par
l'information
mais pas seulement
ce que le patron veut faire dans le parc
c'est de mettre une puce dans la Corne
d'accord donc s'il y a quelqu'un qui
vient et qui coupe la corne quand même
les tracés on sait où la corne est parti
tracker sur le rhinocéros comme sur les
voitures quoi
[Rires]
[Musique]
en 2011 le parc a perdu un rhino
Stéphane m'emmène là où ça s'est passé
les braconniers et malheureusement elle
a été tué avec son bébé car les 18 mois
je vais vous montrer exactement
l'endroit ça s'est passé exactement ici
cet endroit là il faut savoir de nos
jours les braconniers ils viennent pas à
pied ou avec des véhicules ils vont ils
vont louer un hélicoptère donc ce qui
s'est passé ils sont venus pleine lune
faut savoir que plein de hélicoptère la
nuit
sont équipés ils ont des des génies par
balles ils ont des haka 47 bon et ils
viennent avec des chaines sauce avec des
tronçonneuses tronçonneuses pour couper
en 5 minutes en 5 minutes le boulot est
fait
hélicoptère et armes de guerre les
braconniers sont sans limite pour ce
trafic qui est l'un des plus rentables
du monde alors pour sauver les derniers
rinaux ce parc a pris l'ultime mesure
le soir venu des hommes à pied
investissent la savane ce sont des
mercenaires ex soldats leur mission est
très risquée le danger vient bien sûr
des braconniers qui n'hésitent pas à
tirer mais aussi des rhinaux qui peuvent
charger
maintenant le parquet évite de visiteurs
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
mes hommes vont se déployer et protéger
les rhinocéros chacun d'eux à pied à
distance d'un Rhino
toute la nuit toute la nuit jusqu'à
demain matin chacun d'eux a un rhino à
protéger un rhino pour un homme qu'il
surveille un rhino pour un homme c'est
comme un garde du corps
du corps
depuis que vous travaillez dans le parc
aucun rideau
est-ce que des armes je ne peux pas vous
répondre cette information est
confidentielle vous pouvez pas me
répondre non c'est tous ancien soldat
affirmatif et vous même
oui c'est une vraie guerre qui se
déroule ici on m'a dit qu'il y avait des
hélicoptères qui venaient parfois pour
attaquer les rinaux qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez faire contre ça à vous
il y a plusieurs choses que l'on peut
faire contre un hélicoptère mais je ne
peux pas vous dire quoi
si vous avez une
je ne sais pas c'est ma réponse
c'est garde du corps d'un genre
particulier vont prendre leur poste
cette nuit
le lieu est tenu secret
ils sont le dernier rempart dans une
guerre sans merci
c'est la fin de mon séjour mais avant de
quitter Jobourg je veux prendre des
nouvelles du couple Victime d'un
braquage sanglant ce matin réel se rend
au chevet de son compagnon Jérémy
je pourrais faire le chemin en fermant
les yeux depuis le temps
trois semaines qu'il fait la route
plusieurs fois par jour
il y en a je souris mais il faut que je
sois fort pour lui
voilà l'hôpital où jérémy a subi deux
opérations il a perdu la moitié de son
estomac la moitié de son foie
nous n'avons pas le droit de filmer mais
nous confions une petite caméra à
on a priorité c'est de guérir et de
rentrer chez moi
à ce jour les agresseurs du couple n'ont
pas été retrouvés en Afrique du Sud
l'impunité est souvent la règle
les meurtriers du père de Baba n'ont
jamais été arrêtés
tous les ne connaît toujours pas
l'identité de son violeur
le viol de jovo est une affaire classée
et on attend toujours le procès du
policier qui a battu le jeune tatou
sans justice comment réussiront-ils à
faire la paix avec leur passé comment se
pays
pourra-t-il se réconcilier
[Musique]